nah this I'm not no my relationship
pizza is I'm pretty passionate about it
I grew up working in my family's pizza
place so I'm kind of a pizza snob
I'm hoping from this taste test that I
find the pizza place in a way that I can
like call consistently my pizza is good
for what is it what did it right like in
a pinch so let's try this pieces
accurate let's do a quiz see this is a
salad trying to trick me tastes like an
open-faced Mediterranean sandwich so
this is what models eat as a cheat meal
this piece is a really good option if
you want to be gluten free or through
our gluten free or if you are vegan if
someone was like passing this around a
party I would like it but if someone
gave this to me and told me it was pizza
I will fight them
food the signature fold there we go
you've got that joint bro yo no man I
know all right it's surprisingly good
I feel very conflicted right now it's a
bit wet for my taste
Gracie what feeling are you getting from
this Pizza feeling like a matchbox 20
song it's 4:00 a.m. and I'm lonely oh
[Music]
okay I'm gonna like this I can already
tell that looks like a good pizza this
really does look like a New York slice
you got a bubble bubblee you're gonna
want a bubbles this is it this is the
official New York slice in LA all this
grease right here all this that's how
pimples are made I want to like be
hating on El I'm sorry I'll to really
hate on this pizza but you did a good
job there's definitely some good pizza
in LA the best slice we had was like
your average New York slice before this
I would just avoid Le Pisa at all cost
just cuz I knew that it wasn't gonna be
as good but now I know that there are
some slices that are like good enough
when the most important thing LA has New
Yorkers New Yorkers gonna make good
pizza but when you order this or ever
you got this did they describe us as
pizza to you
[Music]